my name is Dylan BTW i am a
systems architect I am also a qualified
scientist as you will discover over the
course of the talk i'm going to give you
this afternoon because what i'm going to
talk to you about today is science and
software development they are
interesting disciplines has anyone in
here studied computer science yeah did
you do any experiments in the course of
becoming a qualified computer scientist
because the idea the premise behind this
talk today is to take a look at some of
the ideas that the scientific community
has used for a long long time to further
understanding of phenomena and
unfamiliar systems to make sense of data
and analyze things and look at how we're
software developers might be able to
apply some of that to what we do the
relationship between computers and
science is complicated and it's one that
has inverted quite dramatically if you
go back a few decades to do any kind of
computing at all you would actually have
to do quite a lot of hands-on science
there was also electronics physics just
to get early computers to boot to work
computing was very very much you know
the idea of solving a problem by running
a computer program it would have to be a
very very sophisticated and important
problem to be able to justify the
scientific resources necessary to get
computer time in order to do it people
would write programs on paper because
computer time was so expensive that
waiting for somebody to type was
unthinkable so you'd write it on paper
you'd punch it on cards you in some
cases send it off by post and you'd get
a report back saying missing semicolon
at line 26 or you know whatever the
problem was and nowadays that
relationship you know has almost
completely inverted and we use computers
now routinely to simulate scientific
phenomenon computing is a big part of an
awful lot of scientific research but
what we're going to do today is to talk
about something called the scientific
method and how I think that can be
applied to improving the development of
software systems
as I said I'm a qualified scientists I
have a bachelor of science in computer
science with image and multimedia
systems from the University of
Southampton I was there for three years
I did no experiments what I did was I
learned about things like the red black
tree and data structures and algorithms
and databases and you know lots and lots
of stuff was presented as this is a fait
accompli this is a fait accompli this is
how you do this this is how you do this
the bias you know it was I had class my
other friends who are in you know
chemistry and biology classes who would
do labs they would on a wednesday
afternoon they would go they would
actually do experiments sometimes they
would express where they didn't know
what was going to happen and they would
actually be investigating something in
the computer science building we had
labs but they were full of Linux
machines and we used them to you know
check email and right scheme programs
and this kind of thing and there was an
interesting contrast that I noticed
because during my time at University
also had a holiday job working for Arab
who are a engineering company and they
built this and they built the Earth's
and bridge and Pompidou Center and all
sorts of things I build none of these my
job was installing windows 3.1 and
wordperfect but the contrast between the
conversations that you would overhear
you know we love metaphors and software
we talk about my job title is architect
that was designed by an architect I
could not design one of those you know
and we talked about build pipelines we
talked about engineering we borrow all
of these metaphors from the construction
industry but it doesn't really add up
because there's one sort of fundamental
difference I want you to imagine that
you are you're starting a new company
and you have some staff and those staff
need a way to be able to write letters
to your customers so you go into a
computer store and you say I need a
software program to write letters and
they say okay well first of all we're
going to need to do a requirements
gathering exercise with you that's all
we'll send a team they'll work with you
for you know six to eight weeks we'll
come up with some ideas work out what it
is that you actually need then we're
going to come up with a tender we will
put that tender out there are maybe 15
companies in this part of the world who
make word processors I'm sure one of
them will be able to help you the whole
thing will probably cost a couple of
million pounds they should be able to
get you a word processor built within 18
months you know it sounds crazy if you
want an office for your new company this
is exactly what you do if you want a
word processor you go into a shop and
you go can you saw me a copy or you go
on to microsoft com and you you know put
in a credit card number and you download
a copy and the you know the contrast
here it is easy to replicate bits of
bits streams of bits data once you've
solved the problem once it's trivial now
there are all sorts of endeavors where
this is not the case engineers who build
bridges once you've built a bridge you
cannot copy and paste it or you know
download it or get bridges off
bittorrent or whatever you do and just
paste them in wherever you need them you
have to build another one starting from
nowhere nothing furniture somebody they
make a chair the next day they make
another chair the next day they make
another chair bicycles musical
instruments artifacts we have this word
in English it's worth masterpiece now
you know masterpiece colloquially in
something that is you know incredibly
intricate and well-executed if it's an
artifact to work of art what masterpiece
originally meant somebody would
apprentice they would start at the very
bottom and they would make a chair and
they'd probably get it wrong and it
would fall apart and they come back and
they'd make another one and another one
and over years you know we're talking
here about people who would develop
these craft and skills over a lifetime
one day they would go I think I'm ready
I think I'm ready now to produce the
ultimate the best chair I will ever
produce to prove that I am now a master
carpenter or a master luthier or a
master builder because over the course
of you know their their apprenticeship
they got to do the same thing over and
over and over again now I want you to
imagine Monday morning or you know
whenever you start your working week you
login or you walk into the office or you
know you report for duty and someone
says we've had a bit of a problem all
the code is gone it's just it's gone all
the hard drives are gone and the backups
are gone on the tapes have been wiped
and github spin taken offline by
attackers it's all every
you were working on has disappeared and
so you got a yacht your client or your
customer your glass you say what do you
want us to do and they say on start
again you know all right here here's a
laptop visual studio off you go whatever
you were working on we need to start it
again so you do you sit down you know
you think okay where were we right we're
building a little marketing website for
a local and no bakery and so you start
working on it putting bits together
pretty good week you come in the next
week they like it happened again we
don't know what keeps happening at the
weekend but someone's coming in and
removing all of our code and you say
what do i do and they say start again
and this keeps happening after three
months how good do you think you would
be at building a marketing website for a
local bakery you've started from scratch
every Monday you know for six months
you've got to go back to square one and
start the whole thing all over again
anyone have a play Super Mario yeah
Super Mario had no save game did it
you've started you plug the cartridge in
and you were there at the beginning of
the first level of the first world and
you started playing until you died when
you died you went back to the beginning
and by the time you got to the end you
could probably do the first half of that
game you know with your eyes closed you
do it in your sleep because you did it
over and over and over until the point
where you no longer made mistakes and
this is why i think you know some of
these ideas are applicable to software
because in software if we have solved a
problem if we have you know come across
a prom before and we have created some
code in order to solve that problem the
code still exists and in most cases the
cost of reuse is I hesitate to say zero
for reasons that will go over shortly
but it is much much easier to take some
code that already exists and apply that
to the problem at hand than it is to go
are you know what I need to put this
list in alphabetical order oh well you
know trying to write a sorting algorithm
I wrote six of those last week and three
the week before and they're all the same
algorithm so I'm getting really good at
it that's not what we do you know we put
together components we take components
and libraries and modules and functions
all of the problems that we know how to
solve it is trivial to reuse the
solution that already exists and this
has a corollary which i think is
dangerous and interesting and very
important to bear in mind because once
you get to the point where you're like
I've looked on the web there's nothing
on stackoverflow there is nothing on
github I can't find anything on the node
package manager or new get there's
nothing in the standard library i'm
going to write some code the fact that
you are writing code means you are doing
something that has not been done before
and in some cases you know this is
really cutting edge stuff you're
building new optimization algorithms for
a heuristic encoding of audio in some
cases this is just our accounts team
have got this package and our you know
sales team have got this package and as
much as we wish it were not the case
apparently nobody in the history of the
world has ever connected these two
packages together before and so there
are these gaps and these gaps aware you
have no idea what you're doing there's
no prior art there is no off-the-shelf
solution there are things that call
themselves best practice but you know
it's dubious how much of a benefit that
really is and so we often find ourselves
in these situations where we are dealing
with an unknown situation something you
know we have to analyze we have to study
we have to try and work out how it all
fits together the computer industry is
not terribly experienced at this because
it is not a very old industry but for
centuries human beings have been
studying these unfamiliar phenomena and
an unfamiliar data sets using something
called the scientific method which is a
toolbox it's a framework it's a
technique for making sense of and
understanding something new something
unfamiliar and it goes like this and
we're going to see this a lot today you
start with an observation whatever it is
that you are working on a system that
you're looking at find out what you can
about it watch it see it in action if
somebody else has worked on it read what
they wrote if you can look up source
code for it look up the source code find
out as much as you can sooner or later
somebody is going to come up with a
question hey can we get the systems
talk to that system hey there's a
problem with performance can you look
into it and these tend to be open-ended
questions and so the next step then
based on your observation formulate a
hypothesis there's a problem with the
database okay I think based on my
observation that the problem is because
this column needs an index something a
statement that you can determine to be
true or false about the system or the
data that you are working with because
once you have a hypothesis you can make
a prediction if I add an index to this
column we are going to see a ninety
percent reduction in the execution time
for this query you design an experiment
whatever it is that you're predicting
how can you you said okay I think if I
do X then Y is going to happen do X find
a way of doing it sometimes this is
trivial and you can do hundreds of these
in a day sometimes this is an entire
life's work but hypothesis prediction
experiment when the experiment is
finished you have data or maybe you have
no data maybe the experiment yielded
nothing the absence of data is still a
data point it is still something that is
worth analyzing and thinking why did I
get nothing you know what what mistake
might I have made what were the flaws in
my prediction communication you've
discovered something publish it share it
make sure people know about it share it
is what it is that you have found so
that the next person to go around the
cycle when they get to the observation
step here they can pick up the things
that you have communicated and not have
to repeat the process that you've been
through now there's a shortcut in this
and optimization which often happens
which is that when you get to the
analysis stage you'll go hang on a
second my hypothesis wasn't quite right
I missed something there was a detail
here that wasn't apparent until I went
in and looked at these data and so you
go back to the hypothesis step and you
go around the circle again now i'm going
to show you an example now one of the
earliest and most famous experiments
that have been done
anyone here got kids running on here no
kids yeah kids are brilliant scientists
except they're not allowed to play with
chemicals or burn things but kids are
curious and kids are like you know daddy
daddy why is the sky blue daddy how does
the Sun work daddy why does it rain
Betty had a rainbow's work now rainbows
are older than humankind they've been
around forever you know people since the
dawn of human humanity have looked up
and seen rainbows and come up with
hypotheses about what these rainbows
might be some people believe that it was
the bow that the Thunder God used to
launch Thunderbolts of the earth because
it's kind of bow shaped some people said
it was the cloak of the Sun God some
people said that it was a rainbow bridge
that connected earth to Valhalla these
are all hypotheses you know these are
people looking at something and going I
got an idea about what that might be
where it comes from um but the
hypothesis are interested in is this guy
Newton Isaac Newton who despite actually
being a deeply spiritual man did not
think that rainbows had anything to do
with God's he had a theory about the
nature of light now when you research
the sort of history of science you will
often find that someone will write
something like Oh everybody believed X
at the time and then there will be in a
citation needed because they don't
actually back this up and there were you
know as far as we can tell there were
various theories about the nature of
light prior to the work that Newton did
one of which was that all light was
fundamentally white and if you wanted
red light you took white light and you
added some red to it and that's what
happened when like summer I would bounce
off a red chair or a red rose or
something just the way it worked with
paint Newton had a different hypothesis
and thanks to the wonder of
communication and the wonder of google
books we can read exactly what his
hypothesis was because his original
manifesto on optics is online where you
can go to this URL and you can look at
it and his hypothesis was I think the
light from the Sun consists of rays
which are different lyra frangible which
is this lovely archaic word for
refracting and they said that lights
which differ in color different degrees
of revenge abilities basically saying I
think white sunlight is actually made up
of all of these different colors all
mixed in together and I think if we were
to
track them we'd see they come out at
different angles so observation Newton
looks up rainbow hypothesis prediction
differ also in degrees of a fringe
valatie the Franj ability this is his
prediction you know experiment the proof
by experiments in a very dark chamber at
a round hole about one third part of an
inch broad made in the shut of a window
I placed a glass prism whereby the beam
of the sun's light which came in might
be refracted upwards towards the
opposite wall now I have a prison and I
don't have a window shutter but I do
have a flashlight because the important
thing about communication in science is
it means that anybody who wants it comes
across you're writing your research does
not have to trust you they can try
exactly the same thing you tried and
they can verify whether it works because
the thing about Newton doesn't have
photographs or anything of his
experiment because cameras hadn't been
invented yet because this was the first
research into optics anyone ever did so
what we can do is we can take a
flashlight and we can take a prism and
if we are lucky we can reproduce exactly
what Newton saw so yeah the people at
the front will tell you this is the
stunning visual spectacle it's
overwhelming um that's exactly what he
did he took it a beam of white light he
shot it through a prism and it came out
in this what we know now is the rainbow
the electromagnetic spectrum he
communicated his results he communicated
them so well that this became absolutely
iconic you know that this image of the
rainbow spectrum pops up in culture all
over the place you've seen this I showed
Rob Connery this earlier and he said you
can't show that without nyan cat so Rob
this one's for you what Newton actually
did was he published a treatise first he
went to the Royal Society in London he
said look I did was amazing experiment
with this this glass prism that I bought
up a fair and this ray of sunlight I
made a rainbow then he published his his
treatise on optics and this you know
with a couple of updates to language and
content on things are still basically
the backbone of
physics curricula on optics I learned
stuff at school and at sixth form
college which are basically straight out
of the stuff Newton wrote centuries ago
and because he did it because he
communicated it we haven't had to do it
again we can build on top there is this
lovely quote Newton wrote to Robert
Hooke one day and he said if I have seen
further than others because I have stood
on the shoulders of giants there is
actually there was a tangential quote
from the father of Visual Basic which is
if scientists are standing on the
shoulders of giants the software
industry is standing on the toes
of other midgets but you know he
communicated these these findings and we
now all of us have you know cameras on
our phones in our pockets we have color
displays we have SLR cameras we have the
Hubble Space Telescope all the stuff is
because people didn't have to start from
square one they could pick up when you
can left off and they could build on
what he had published and generation
upon generation is built on this so how
can we apply that sort of you know
discipline and good stuff to software so
we're selling stuff and we have a check
out and we've just launched a new check
out for our you know ecommerce system
where we're selling a luggage online and
for some reason observation we're seeing
lots of abandoned shopping carts people
are getting on their putting stuff in
there carton and for whatever reason
they're going away they're disappearing
they're not getting any money so we have
a meeting and it's one of those meetings
because dave is in the meeting and dave
doesn't like the people who built the
new check out and davis kicked his heels
and in baivers is absolutely adamant
that Nona the reason we're seeing
abandoned things because the design is
rubbish people don't like yet they're
getting to the checkout system and
they're going on i'm not giving these
people my money you ever had one of
those meetings whether then degenerates
into like an argument where it's like no
one is bringing any new information to
this it's just two people hoping the
other one is going to run out of
patience and they're going to win
because they're still shouting I don't
want to have those kinds of discussions
anymore I want to do science so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
this observation I'm going to say ok
Dave we think maybe you are correct you
have this this idea that people are
dumping the shopping cart because they
don't like the design
that's a hypothesis so observation
shopping carts are getting abandoned
hypothesis they are getting abandoned
because people do not like the design
prediction if we show people alternative
designs this one will what's the word
played badly against alternatives we
will see a a sort of pronounced drop-off
in the number of people who convert in
order using this shopping cart versus
the previous design how would you design
an experiment to go in and validate this
there's an idea we have in software
something called a be testing come
across this concept he loves to of
something and one bunch of people sees
one of them and one bunch of people sees
the other one and you track how those
groups of users behave it's hard to do
it's hard to do if you have small user
groups it's hard to do if you have a
code base that doesn't support it but it
is also an incredibly valuable technique
for better understanding the way people
are using the systems you're creating so
we design an experiment when people
arrive on our website we are going to
use some mechanism to split them equally
into two groups a and B and group a are
all going to get the old shopping cart
that hasn't been redesigned and Group B
are all going to get the new one pretty
simple right we conduct the experiment
now if you switch it on for Hafner I'd
read anecdotally somewhere if Amazon
want to try a new feature on a thousand
people they switch it on for 17 seconds
most of us do not have this luxury so
when you are conducting your experiment
gathering your data do it over a period
of time that you get enough data that
it's actually representative you know
run it for a couple of weeks so you get
the people who are shopping online at
work during the lunch hour you get the
people who are shopping online late at
night you get the people who do shopping
over the weekend let it run for a while
let it run so you have a statistically
significant volume of data to analyze
then analyze the data and so at this
point we've got all of these check out
logs and all this data for all these
people we communicate it we have another
meeting we're like we didn't see any
correlation whatsoever you know people
going through the old checkout system
forty-one percent of them never
completed the transaction people going
through the new checkout system
thirty-eight percent of them never
completed the transaction to within a
degree of experimental error we don't
think there's any correlation there and
that's when someone in the meeting pops
up and goes hey while i was looking
through this data into something i
noticed but a lot of the people who
weren't completing their transactions
using firefox so I now have bang a new
hypothesis I think there might be a
problem that means people who are using
Mozilla Firefox can't get through our
payment processing system so let's go
around again prediction if we try and
buy luggage on our website using Firefox
something is going to go wrong
experiment in this one doesn't even need
a be testing you grab someone who has
Firefox and you say hey can you go try
and buy something on a live web site and
by the way when you do this be sure to
use the company credit card because if
you buy something from your own company
using your credit card and then try and
claim it back on expenses you create an
infinite loop in the tax system and all
the money disappears down it and they go
through and sure enough you know in the
scenario they get to the experimental
stage analysis yeah our credit card
provider who we outsource do they have a
new extended validation certificate
Firefox is not supporting it
communication go on Twitter and complain
write a blog post file a support ticket
tell all the other people in the meeting
you know yet the fact out there we've
just discovered something that we don't
think anyone else knew because when we
look for it we couldn't find it which is
the easy card calm doesn't work with
firefox with their new certificate and
you go around again except we've learned
something but we haven't actually fixed
the problem we know what's causing it we
have a much better understanding now of
the system that we are we are dealing
with of the problem that we're trying to
solve but what we have not done is
delivered a solution now that is a
really important distinction because
when you are doing experiments there is
often this danger that people are going
to think that the experiment is actually
the product so here is a website
prototype have you ever had the
experience where you've built a high
fidelity prototype something you show it
to one of your customers are your
clients and they like yeah that that's
nice that's nice that's nice click click
click click brilliant when does it go
live and you say three months from now
and they're like what you mean that
looks finished and you say this is not
finished this is a prototype this is an
experiment we just built this to put in
front of people to make sure that our
designs were valid and as far as they
can see from you know some basic
interactions and you know sort of very
high level assessment of what the thing
looks like it's not an experiment it's
finished it looks real there are two
things we can do to work around this one
of them is if you are doing experiments
make them look like experiments there is
a prototyping tool that I use which is
called axia and I love Axia because it
literally has a little slider another
screens called sketchiness you can build
a high fidelity prototype and then you
can go right make this fifty percent
sketchy like you know back of a napkin
take all the colors out turn all the
images into place holders put in the
lovely awesome handwriting font and then
publish that to the intranet so i can go
and show it off in a meeting and people
go oh yeah this is and at that point you
know the bit of their brain that thinks
this is finished and shiny doesn't even
kick in there going okay so we're just
looking at great boxers here can i work
out what the boxers do so don't be
afraid to do this you know if you're
doing sprint planning and you have
something which is unknown it's often a
pattern someone's like how long's it
going to take you like infinite you're
thinking well we don't know but we think
it will probably take two days to find
out how it works and then probably
another two to fix it so you'll say yet
ended four days say end of the week why
not say to them I tell you what why
don't you give us two days to
investigate and then we'll get back
together on wednesday and we can tell
you you know maybe our investigation was
successful maybe our investigation is
just this is a massive can of worms and
we genuinely have no idea but we are
going to take two days and we are
actually going to we're place or i work
we put
tickets in which our investigation
tickets with acceptance criteria of we
understand this someone has written up
it's on the wiki and we're not starting
in the dark when we actually come to
implement this thing and it's quite a
useful technique for getting people to
buy into especially if you can involve
them in the process of you know
designing the experiment you said well
what do you want to see what do you
think is going to happen you know if
you're doing experiments make them
experiments the other thing that you can
do which is a sort of slightly more
controversial approach so this is fred
brooks mythical man months it's a great
book about computer science the language
in it is sexist as hell because it
refers to all engineers as men but apart
from that it has some fairly sort of
interesting points in it and he makes a
great point in this he's talking about
something called a pilot system and the
exact quote he says is the management
question is not whether to build a pilot
system and throw it away you will do
that the only question is whether you
plan in advance to build a throwaway or
you promise to deliver the throwaway to
your customers the first version of
whatever you build is not going to be
right it will be the wrong product or it
will be the right product and it doesn't
work properly it will have defects
because you will learn so much about the
problem you're trying to solve in the
process of solving it that your initial
ideas will mostly turn out to be wrong
and so you know in the 1960s when this
was written you know Fred Brooks is
writing in a decade that built Apollo
and Boeing 747 you know big engineering
where you can't really fail fast and
cheap because spacecraft and airliners
don't fail cheap ever they do fail fast
but that's not really the point but you
know in modern software we have
continuous delivery and application
updates and lots of stuff is online and
cloud-based we have a whole different
idea which is we can actually engage the
customers and we can say we're going to
do an experiment and we actually want
you to be in it you know we're going to
ship something very very small we're
going to ship something that the MVP the
Minimum Viable Product actually the
thing i like to call it is the MLP the
minimum loveable product often the
smallest thing that's viable isn't
actually going to get people necessarily
engaged with it but you make those
stakeholders your customers part of that
process you say it is an experiment and
we may end up throwing
away but we want you to help us refine
that approach and the trade-off you get
the benefit of doing that is you get to
do it very very quickly now there is an
old joke Rene Descartes goes into a
restaurant and at the end of dinner the
waiter says would you like anything else
he says I'd like a cup of coffee without
cream the waiter goes to the kitchen and
comes back a few minutes later he says
I'm very sorry Monsieur the cart the
kitchen has run out of cream would you
like coffee without milk there's another
version which is where Rene Descartes is
working as an agile consultant and he's
with a client and they're talking about
their planning process and he says to
them you know the agile manifesto says
that we should respond to change over
following a plan and the customer serves
to him al that's brilliant we don't have
a plan and they card says that's crazy
if you don't have a plan how can you
choose not to follow it it's the
illusion of choice there are
organizations who think that I was great
because it means that you can throw away
your ideas about what you're doing it is
important to have a plan it is important
to have a vision which is this never
happens but the vision is what you are
going to do if you don't learn anything
new and if nothing changes now there's a
trap that a lot of organizations fall
into where you have a vision say that
that looks like this across the top we
have business features requirements down
the left we have technical requirements
layers you know processes steps of
implementation there is a very old
school way of approaching software where
you stay right this is our vision this
is our design first we are going to
design the architecture for all of it
once we've got that we will build the
data layer as soon as we have the data
layer then the business logic can be
implemented easily once we have business
logic will put a user interface on it
then we will launch it then we will get
feedback now this feedback will be in
the form of hundreds of people saying
nasty things about your new product on
Twitter and phoning helpdesk and filing
bugs and generally saying you built this
thing that doesn't work and nothing
works the way it's supposed to and what
have you been doing for the last six
months and probably eventually someone
will go look we're getting really fed up
of going phone calls all the time
because the thing we thought we fixed is
broken could we please put some
monitoring on this so at least we know
about it
for the phone starts to ring what if you
did it this way pick a feature one thing
that is actually useful and ship that
all the way to production instead of
getting hundreds of nasty tweets you'll
get tens maybe five maybe none if it's
small enough and you've got the people
involved so that they know that you're
still knocking the edges off talk to
them see what it is that they want next
brilliant they want that now based on
that you realize that your original
vision was wrong and actually the next
thing is not necessarily to go ABCDE
you're going to jump and you're going to
ship this thing next and at every stage
you are making sure each iteration of
this each experiment you are picking
smallest thing that can work you are
shipping it you are communicating you
are analyzing data you are going back to
the observation stage and you're feeding
that back into the next iteration of
your product because what you probably
find is that you can do DNA and see
actually it turns out you never needed
that at all you had this entire piece of
your vision your product vision that
through repeated experiments you
determine that the hypothesis said it
was necessary has turned out to be false
the point about these experiments the
data the analysis that happens when
you're doing agile product development
you can't get that without talking to
the people who are actually using it and
a lot of old school project management
techniques have a sort of you know Gantt
chart will do a design phase then we'll
do the implementation phase then we'll
do a testing phase when we finish
testing it will launch it and we'll have
a bit of time at the end to fix the bugs
this never works this never ever works
because the things you learn at this
stage you really want to find out when
you were over here now I this is
anecdotal but based on my experience if
you're doing a piece of development take
the time from officially starting it to
the time when a real customer first gets
their hands on it at the very earliest
that is going to be halfway if you're
eight months into a project and you
haven't shipped anything yet and you're
going to be at least into the right
months if you are two years into a
project that you're confident is going
to be a two year project it's not it's
going to be a four-year project unless
someone's already using it
and that's a lower bound you know it
gets worse you could be three months
into what you think it's a six-month
project it's actually going to go on for
three or four years or it's going to get
canceled because the costs spiral and I
think in all of these cases this is
because you cannot do this experimental
you cannot apply this the scientific
method without getting valid data to
inform your observations and your next
round of hypotheses and you can't do
that until you've shipped okay so to
wrap up this afternoon I'm going to show
you some statements things that people
in our industry say and then go on and
do things as though they were true and
between us I want to have a bit of a
talk about how would you actually design
a scientific experiment to validate
whether these hypotheses were true or
not so someone says to you must not my
code it must be a problem in the
database something which happens quite a
lot experiment how would you turn this
hypothesis into a prediction and how
would you then test that prediction
experimentally open the debugger see if
the code is behaving correctly that'll
be one way of doing it what would that
tell you you're gonna grab the mic sir
is code then you would see the code
behaving in correctly in the debugger
and if it wasn't you you know it could
at least be a problem in the database
okay so a bit so we have a prediction
there that if you look at the code and
the debugger then if it's not there code
the debugger will show no problems and
you can validate its the database is
there another way you can approach it so
we got two components here and we're
trying to determine scientifically which
one of them contains a defect isolation
test run the database on its own the
prediction there well if it's a problem
in the database then the database will
still exhibit the problem even if your
code isn't involved so we'll go and
we'll run this thing in isolation we
actually we had this very thing went
round and round and round and my team
for a long long time a few years ago we
were using nhibernate which is a RM
third net which was very very popular
about another five years ago and we had
literally a bunch of queries that code
looked fine the data looked fine when
you put them together it didn't work and
it went backwards and forwards
developers saying the code is absolutely
fine it must be the database we took the
queries and literally we have copy and
paste the query from the debugger into
the database and it would work perfectly
and then you'd put it back and it turned
out that the reason why i know--this was
working was an hibernate was passing
everything as a Unicode string and all
of our indexes were on anti strings and
that doesn't show up in any of the
debuggers that took a long time to get
through but you know that was literally
breaking it down into these little steps
right if we try x we think why is going
to happen and eventually it came down to
if we specify one of these parameters as
a dotnet string and run the code in
isolations are still going to exhibit
the problem and it did it's like right
let's taught us something so we want to
another statement dependency injection
makes everything in pure is this true
so this was I'm from mark Siemens talk
yesterday he's talking about Haskell and
functional programming and stuff and
this went on Twitter and several people
shed it clearly they think this and
wisdom here do we think it's true could
you design an experiment to test it yes
you don't need an experiment you can
mathematically prove it this is not
masters of science there will be
experiment how would you prove it while
you would build a simple mathematical
model of a programming language where
you have effects can take lambda
calculus if you wish yeah and then you
will write a formal formalism of what is
a dependency injection and you'll write
a proof that says if I use this then
this is where effects are happening and
therefore it's not pure without yeah
well that's exactly the point I was
coming on to is we have this well in
here in pure and we also have dependency
injection I think there is now a
reasonable degree of consensus in our
industry about what dependency injection
is but purity is one of those words like
better or faster or more efficient which
you need to understand all the people
who are trying to evaluate the truth of
the statement need to agree on what pure
and impure means in the context of
developing software systems because
until you actually understand what it is
you're trying to test how do you know
what are you hoping to learn from from
conducting the experiment object
oriented development means your code can
easily be reused in other programs who
in here is or has been a no developer
who's still an arrow developer
is object oriented development better
than what you were using before does it
allow code to be reused more easily in
other programs could you design an
experiment and if so how would you
conduct it so we have this word in here
easily what is Eve in this context how
would you be scientifically rigorous
about your definition of ease of code
reuse so spin up two teams this is one
of those interesting experiments you get
in fields like sociology where they're
like we're actually going to do things
with two big sample groups and although
a lot of sociological and psychological
research follows the sort of observation
hypothesis approach it's often very
difficult to reproduce their experiments
because you can't get enough
experimental subjects because you don't
have enough funding but you could
potentially do this you could get to
software teams and you could say right
your team are going to use any
object-oriented paradigm you like Java C
sharp C++ you are going to do everything
procedural and just for fun you're gonna
have another thing you're going to use
Haskell you're going to do everything
pure functional and then you would need
to come up with some objective metric
about ease of code reuse now in a good
idea that would be cyclomatic complexity
of the systems that they're actually
building you know if you've got easy
code reuse it makes sense that most of
your use cases and your features will
actually end up flowing through the same
elements of your code the same discrete
function points and things so you could
potentially do an analysis of a code
base and then you say that the
developers well how easy was it to get
it to do that how long did it take how
many hours have you spent working on
this you know it's interesting you take
these statements which often you know
entire massive teams of hundreds of
people have done c for c++ because they
believe this statement to be true
without ever actually going what are we
expecting to see you know what's the
hypothesis were predicting here because
often you know experience there are
entire companies out there where the
company is actually a hypothesis that
they're hoping will pay off if we build
an app that lets people summon cabs
using their smartphone it'll get used
and it will be successful
hypothesis that one worked if we post
people a little plastic cat that lives
from scan barcodes and magazines to go
to web addresses that was a hypothesis
that didn't work which is why everyone's
heard of uber and no one's heard of the
cue cat you know often startups are
these little ideas that they think if
this is true and then they bet an entire
company on it and you think could you
have done something smaller could there
be an experimental way of validating
this developers who attend conferences
write better code than developers who
don't experimental validation required
[Laughter]
exactly how do you quantify better is it
code that has more shiny things in it it
is code that's easier to read is it code
that runs faster is it code that has a
lower total cost of ownership over the
course of five or ten years you know a
lot of people use this all I need to go
to conferences so I'll be a better
developer that's why okay well you'll
probably be a happier developer is that
necessarily the same thing I'd love to
see it analysis of this one our team
will be more productive if we have daily
stand-up meetings again we have this
weasel word more productive unless
you're tracking two teams of identical
people trying to hit identical targets
using one of them's doing stand-ups the
other one isn't it's very hard to get
the experimental data little better
rubies better than PHP you'll notice a
pattern in these an awful lot of the
things that people use in software to
inform the decisions we make have these
words easily better more efficient
faster it's all comparative it's very
seldom is there an objective we we
predict that the following thing is
going to happen we use these sort of
felling nebulous terms and it's
interesting trying to break those down
and think well what do you actually mean
by better in this context the most
efficient and effective method of
conveying information to and within a
development team is face-to-face
conversation this is one of the
assumptions the principles underlying
the agile manifesto I know some teams
who swear by it I know some teams who
are like that's completely wrong and
it's optimizing for all of the wrong
thing
again do you think you could
experimental e-verify this depends what
you're optimizing for what is an
efficient method conveying information
to and with the development team who are
all in the same room at the same time
sure if the development team are not in
the same room or they are in the same
room that they're not in the same room
at the same time the people who are
working different shifts the people who
are working are different time zone they
have no access to the content of that
face-to-face conversation is that
efficient or effective depends on the
team it depends on what you're
optimizing for okay that's pretty much
it for me today we have a few minutes
for questions if anybody has any
questions or on the other hand if
everyone has achieved total
enlightenment yes so I think one of the
interesting sort of things you could see
at the end with that in physics yeah
when people say things it's like fairly
clear to figure out what do they mean by
it yes and if we were to use scientific
method for programming yeah we would
need some clear things too so this claim
as well yeah and it looked like none of
the circus things you were showing in
the end we're particularly Scientifics
because they didn't make any clear
claims so do you think there's like do
you think those are just things that
people shouldn't be saying at all or do
you think there are some other good
things that they should be think instead
those are things that in most cases I
deliberately chose because a lot of
people would agree with them but it is
very very difficult to kind of take a
rigorous approach on determining whether
they're true or not you know there are
lots of things you can say in software
you know I have I mentioned an example
earlier the database index I think if i
add this index sequel server will do
this for you it'll go if you put this
index on this table you will see on
ninety nine point six percent
improvement in the performance of this
query and you can test that and most of
the time it's pretty close you know you
can in many cases make you're working
with ok we have a late
via 500 milliseconds talking for remote
service if we reduce the number of
remote service calls from 20 calls to
five the total latency of our user
interface will drop from 10 seconds to
two and a half seconds you know these
kinds of predictions are not terribly
controversial because as you say there
are more akin to physics and you know
other other forms of more mathematically
rooted science but we make fairly big
and fairly expensive and significant
decisions based on things that we think
are true and it's interesting to me to
look at these and think well how do you
actually break that down you know what
do you reduce it to any other questions
great in that case thank you very much I
would ask for your help and verifying
one more piece of experimental data I
have a hypothesis that people who give
green feedback will go on to live long
and happy lives if you'd like to be part
of this experiment is very easy you put
in a green card and then go and live
happy ever after or it doesn't work out
let me know yeah but then I need to all
get you back in ten years and you know
then we'd be trying to measure happiness
scientifically and only the Danes can do
that anyway thank you all very much for
coming enjoy the rest of the conference
enjoy the party tonight I'll see you
around thank you